economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos este bloque en
perú porque allí buscan aprobar también
el retiro de las pensiones públicas
siguiendo ya esos pasos que ya hicieron
con el sistema privado de pensiones allí
sí santiago buenas noches mire en mayo
se aprobó el retiro parcial del 25 por
ciento de lo que al menos 75 millones de
trabajadores tenían en su fondo de
pensiones privado esto con el fin de
ayudar a superar la crisis ahora son los
legisladores quienes promueven que los
afiliados al fondo público que no hayan
completado a los 20 años legales de
cotización también puedan acceder sino a
todo al menos a un porcentaje de su
dinero un motivo de tensión con el
gobierno que no está de acuerdo con esta
propuesta nos explica un experto en
france 24
la gente que ha aportado 5 10 15 19 años
no va a respirar de ficción los 60 y
congresos del perú están planteando que
se les devuelva ese dinero que han
ahorrado pero el problema en el sistema
público gusta ese dinero para financiar
a lo que hoy día están compilado y si
les quitan ese dinero el problema es
cómo van a financiar a los que ya están
con cuidado
daniela también destacado el día de hoy
que tick tock demandó a eeuu por esas
acciones que promovió en su contra la
aplicación de vídeos respondió así a la
prohibición de donald trump de que las
empresas estadounidenses hagan algún
tipo de transacción o negocio con esta
compañía a partir del 15 de septiembre
específicamente tick tock dice que el
jefe de la casa blanca violó el derecho
del proceso y que no tiene evidencias
reales de que esta empresa afecte su
seguridad nacional
el gobierno chino apoyo en la medida
legal que además rechaza que eeuu busca
forzar la venta
china apoya a las empresas en la toma de
armas legales para salvaguardar sus
derechos e intereses los abusos contra
ciertas compañías como tick tock por
parte de algunos políticos
estadounidenses son esencialmente un
acoso económico sistemático y organizado
sobre empresas no estadounidenses que
toman la iniciativa en ciertos campos
daniela y pensé que el peso colombiano
pierde terreno ante el dólar los
colombianos ahora están en el top 5 de
los más compradores de propiedad raíz en
eeuu como le parece pues esto es por
primera vez en la historia de acuerdo
con un estudio de la national
association of realtors que es una
organización de agentes de ventas de
propiedades residenciales el informe
dice que entre abril de 2010 y 9 y mayo
de 2020 los colombianos casi duplicaron
su inversión en propiedad raíz de eeuu
pasaron de 800 millones de dólares a
1300 millones de dólares en apenas un
año
de esta manera subieron en el ranking de
compradores que lidera méxico y al que
le siguen china india y canadá o mejor
que están antes de colombia según el
informe de florida sigue siendo el
estado preferido para los compradores
extras
con más del 20 por ciento de las
operaciones cuando vamos y compramos
daniela después de más de 100 días de
parálisis económica entró en vigor la
apertura económica de el salvador sí
señor la particularidad que tiene este
país y que la diferencia de otras
naciones es que la normalización
programada por el gobierno de nadie
bukele iba a ser gradual sin embargo la
corte suprema dijo que tenía que ser
inmediata eso quiere decir que a partir
de este lunes todos los negocios
empresas centros comerciales y otros
lugares de servicios varios ya tienen
abiertas sus puertas luego de cuatro
meses cerrados pero sólo si cumplen con
las normas sanitarias una noticia menos
alentadora santiago sobre todo para las
pequeñas empresas que se estima son ocho
de cada diez afectadas por la pandemia y
que podrán cerrar en cualquier momento
pasamos ahora los indicadores sí señor
wall street' de seropositivo y
alessandra en pulso conformado por las
500 empresas más grandes rompió el
récord alcanzado previamente en febrero
en europa los mercados también
estuvieron animados por las buenas
noticias sobre avances en tratamientos y
vacunas contra el coronavirus buen
avance en fráncfort
y la tendencia se interrumpió en américa
latina en donde si hubo descensos en
especial en argentina y en méxico
mientras que brasil subió bueno daniela
muchas gracias por esta actualización de
las noticias de economía gracias por
estos datos y ustedes pueden seguir con
la información aquí en france24 siga con
nosotros feliz noche
[Música]